day one we are shown some prisoners in a
cell everything seems to be going as
usual but just then one of the men
starts coughing up blood profusely it is
now day seven and all the men in the
cell start dying one by one due to the
unknown virus by the end of the month
thousands of men have died and they are
mass buried by women who for some reason
are unaffected by the virus eight years
later the viral plague has wiped out all
of the men and earth has become a planet
run by and for women with no men around
the women have set up a repopulation
lottery which is run by an organization
called wellness it is a robust and just
process for selecting women who get to
deliver a healthy future to keep the
earth's population stable they allocate
sperm from the world's pre-virus sperm
banks in new zealand a lucky woman named
jaime is selected out of hundreds of
participants she runs a dairy farm with
her friend pip and sister-in-law alex
jaime used to have a son and loving
husband jackson before she lost them
during the plague jaime's friend pip
works for the wellness organization
while alex is an outspoken critic of the
organization the latter has been sent to
jail numerous times for attacking and
cursing lane the wellness organization's
leader in fact she has been to jail so
many times that she has even managed to
have a romantic affair with her parole
officer constance whenever alex is sent
back home from jail the police inject a
bliss ball in her body that keeps her
temporarily sedated and under control
one day when alex returns home from jail
she wakes up to an empty home as she is
heavily sedated by the bliss ball she
doesn't remember anything however as she
gets up she finds several notes
throughout the house which instructs her
on how to remove the bliss balls from
her back turns out that she wrote the
instructions herself as she is used to
getting apprehended by the authorities
doing is told she performs an incision
and removes the ball leaving the house a
bloody mess she then goes to meet her
mother it's revealed that alex's mother
has been sent into a state of permanent
bliss as punishment for going against
the wellness which explains the former's
hatred towards the organization when
jaime and pip return home they find alex
missing upon seeing blood everywhere
they assume the worst and begin to panic
after collecting themselves they quickly
get in their truck and head out to look
for her out of nowhere someone appears
before their truck and they
unintentionally knock the person over
fearing the worst they assume that they
just killed alex but to their relief
alex appears from another direction
confirming that they ran someone else
over to their horror they learned that
it is a man the girls are shocked by the
revelation as they were previously told
that all men were wiped off from the
earth thinking that they just killed the
last man on earth they start panicking
but just then the man regains
consciousness however he is severely
injured so the girls rush him into a
barn there the girls get into a minor
argument and pip suggests they should
immediately hand over the man to
wellness but alex strongly opposes it
according to her the man should be
treated in the barn itself after a lot
of convincing pip eventually gives in
and the girls start treating the man
after a lot of time and effort the
surgery is successful and the girls fall
asleep in the barn tired the next day
when the girls wake up they notice
lane's assistant michelle's car pulling
up in their driveway pip again insists
on telling michelle about the man but
jamie convinces her against it as it
could jeopardize her chances of becoming
a mother again it is revealed that jaime
dearly misses her late husband and son
she feels that she can fill that void by
having another baby meanwhile michelle
has approached the trio to check the
living conditions of the place she
interviews jaime and pip to see if they
are fit to welcome a baby into their
home meanwhile alex wakes up and starts
going through the man's backpack she
learns that his name is bobby and he has
a newspaper clipping of an article about
her mother who is a former biochemist
bobby suddenly wakes up and tries to run
away but alex stops him and a struggle
follows unfortunately michelle hears the
commotion and insists on inspecting the
barn jaime and pip try to persuade her
against going there but michelle is
adamant fortunately when she reaches
there alex has already brought the
situation under control later jaime is
informed that she didn't make it to the
next stage of the wellness program much
to her dismay she breaks down and calls
pip the latter calms her down and
promises to be by her side after work
later pip approaches lane and asks her
if there has been any mix-up regarding
her friend's candidacy however this just
enrages lane who accuses pip of
questioning the wellness's selection
methods elsewhere alex questions bobby
about the newspaper article and when he
refuses to speak she proceeds to inject
the bliss ball into his body however she
can't bring herself to go through with
the process after a horrible memory of
her mother being injected with the same
substance in a fit of rage alex destroys
the pill it's then revealed that the
wellness organization put a permanent
pill in her mother's body after the old
woman claimed to have seen some male
survivors meanwhile bobby sympathizes
with alex and claims that there are more
male survivors and they are being hunted
in the next scene jamie goes to the
official gynecologist of wellness dr
harvey to see if she got rejected due to
some medical reasons to her disbelief dr
harvey reveals that she had in fact
approved jaime for the next stage
desperate for a baby jaime goes to bobby
to get his sperm but she ends up
breaking down in front of him soon pip
arrives and sends jaime back home
promising to help her moments later she
emerges from the barn with bobby's sperm
and hands it to jaime the next day jaime
meets a woman at a store who is also
rejected by wellness and is able to
resonate with her meanwhile pip again
hounds bobby for his sperm to make sure
that jaime has abundant sperm to get
pregnant as part of a bargain she lets
him shower under her supervision which
ends up arousing her later alex offers
bobby drinks in order to win his trust
and make him open up about wellness
however she ends up getting drunk and
bobby uses this opportunity to free
himself and run away sadly he is not
able to get far because of his injury
and he's forced to return he then shows
a half-conscious alex a sim card that he
says could lead them to a place where
other survivors have been kept at night
jaime keeps thinking about the woman
from the bakery so she decides to
anonymously give her bobby's sperm the
next day jaime finds pip lurking around
the barn and figures out that she
fancies bobby pip denies being attracted
to bobby but jaime refuses to believe
her meanwhile alex eventually finds a
phone and when she turns it on with
bobby's sim they find a message from an
unknown number saying rise at work pip
notices the sperm recipient woman being
pilled turns out that the wellness have
gotten wind of a living man so they are
vigorously searching for him alarmed she
informs jaime and the others about the
development she then sneaks out of work
and joins them at the farm the
organization eventually traces the sperm
back to the farm and sends police for a
raid while hiding behind the barn alex
holds jaime responsible for the
situation and decries not being able to
return back to the farm which belonged
to her late brother jackson suddenly
bobby's phone rings and a man from the
other end shares an address with him
elsewhere an unknown woman is seen
intercepting their conversation the
group decides to hide at the site where
jackson and other sick men were burned
to death to contain the plague there the
unknown woman finds them and starts
chasing them with a dart gun forcing the
group to flee in their car bobby reveals
that the woman is a hunter and she
killed his friend two weeks ago while
trying to get rid of the hunter the
group gets stuck in the festivities of
syncfest a festival that celebrates
menstruation with no other choice but to
participate bobby disguises himself as
the festival's mascot soon lane and the
hunter also arrive at the festival and
the group gets separated in the crowd
amidst the chaos jaime vomits and
realizes that she has gotten pregnant
meanwhile pip is spotted by lane and the
latter asks her about bobby she offers
to forgive her friends and give her a
seat at the wellness committee in
exchange for the information meanwhile
alex and bobby notice the former's
mother in the wellness crowd and walk up
to her however they are quickly spotted
by hunter prompting bobby to run and
causing alex's mother to panic alex
calms her mother down before leaving to
join jaime soon pip also joins the girls
and tries to talk to them about lane's
offer but they all drag her along to the
reflection labyrinth where bobby has
taken refuge from hunter however the
labyrinth is extremely confusing and
hunter manages to sedate bobby and leave
with him in her truck fortunately jaime
manages to get on the back of her truck
without being noticed she follows hunter
and bobby into a secret base and manages
to sedate her with one of her own darts
with this jaime safely rescues him from
hunter's place and informs him that she
has gotten pregnant with his sperm a
while later alex and pip also reunite
with jamie and bobby the group then
starts heading towards the address on
their way there bobby suggests that he
goes to meet the man alone and the women
could join him later this starts an
argument and amid the chaos they don't
notice that pip has driven them back to
the wellness center as a reward pip is
taken to a luxurious room while alex and
jaime are taken into custody alex
eventually learns about jaime's
pregnancy and requests lane to let her
go however lane tells her that jaime
will meet the same fate as her mother in
the next scene pip is made to change
into nice clothes and taken to the
committee member's dinner bobby is also
at the table along with the wellness
ladies but with his hands tied pip tries
to talk to him but he is expectedly
upset with her however lane encourages
them to kiss this enrages bobby and he
attacks lane sadly the other girls
quickly overpower him and pin him on the
dinner table lane then pulls his shirt
up and instructs pip to make love to him
as alex's cop lover constance watches it
all transpire when pip hesitates lane
gets angry and threatens to kick her out
of the committee if she doesn't comply
pip initially gets on top of bobby but
seeing him so uncomfortable she
confronts lane she accuses her of trying
to build a new world and placing herself
at the top pip's resistance seems to
move other girls so lane quickly orders
constance to take her into custody she
takes pip to the operating room where
two nurses are gearing up to permanently
send alex and jamie into a state of
bliss constance tells the nurses to
operate on pip first as per lane's order
to pip surprise when the nurses proceed
to make preparations for the procedure
constance sedates them after waking up
alex and jamie constance asks the girls
to sedate her so the organization
wouldn't suspect her role in their
escape and alex tearfully complies after
reaching a safe place alex expresses her
anger towards pip for betraying their
trust on the other hand pip breaks into
tears and profusely apologizes for her
mistake the girls share an intense
emotional moment and eventually forgive
each other the girls then arm themselves
with farm tools and intercept lane's car
on her way to hand bobby over to the
government they tase her and manage to
free bobby but he refuses to come with
them an angry bobby then expresses that
he was much happier and free all of
those eight years when he wasn't around
women meanwhile lane regains
consciousness and holds bobby at
gunpoint however alex swiftly jumps in
front of bobby challenging lane to shoot
her before him jamie and pip follow suit
and the girls eventually manage to
sedate lane again the girls then realize
that bobby has taken off without them
next they notice a wellness car
approaching them so they quickly take
cover in the bushes elsewhere bobby
makes his way towards the address which
turns out to be an abandoned sports
ground soon the girls reunite with him
there much to his dismay he feels that
the surviving men won't accept him with
the women around so he tries to get rid
of them but hunter arrives as she
explains that she is there to protect
bobby all the exits to the building shut
down and a toxic gas is released hunter
quickly opens an air duct and helps
everyone climb it however before she can
escape she tells alex that she's just
like her mother and starts losing
consciousness taken aback alex notices
her mother's tattoo in the woman's hand
the gas then engulfs the room and the
group is forced to continue they crawl
their way through the duct but it keeps
getting narrower and they eventually get
stuck with the gas fast approaching them
from behind the group starts shaking
violently until the duct gives way and
they fall down to their horror they find
themselves in a room where a group of
naked men are being milked for their
sperm
i'm sorry lane and dr harvey appear and
it's revealed that they are stockpiling
fresh sperm so when the government runs
out of supplies of pre-virus sperm they
could control the population the country
and possibly the world the episode ends
as jackson appears out of nowhere and
lane reveals that he's the architect of
all of this much to alex and jaime's
shock and horror subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching